she's a kid
that's what happens when you trying to
be a hero Batman Arkham VI is short its
gameplay is rudimentary and his story
retreads old ground by also has these
moments that for fans of The Dark Knight
are the ultimate expression of wish
fulfillment like many I have a personal
connection to Batman my childhood was
spent watching him on screens and
reading him on pages so when our
conveyor placed me into the living room
of Wayne Manor lowered me into its
stately bowels and dropped me into the
Batcave the sense of being fully
immersed in a world I know so intimately
stirred emotions within me like no other
game has this sense of being totally
immersed in Gotham see is Batman Arkham
vos biggest strength but at the same
time it's impossible to ignore how
shallow my interactions with the world
were the hour or so it takes to finish
the game is made up of the kind of
perfunctory motion controlled gameplay
seen in early Wii games using the
PlayStation Move controller I poked our
buttons to boo computers flicked
batarangs our switches and shot the
grapnel gun to pull in items its agency
at its most elementary the two most
significant gameplay sections involve
investigating a crime scene and
conducting an autopsy the crime scene
investigation plays out much like it did
in Batman Arkham origins with players
scrubbing backwards and forwards through
an augmented reality reenactment of a
crime to piece together the events to
unravel what happened Batman uses an
evidence scanner which you physically
pull out from your utility belt the
device is used like a flashlight to
locate and scan key pieces of
information that pushed the
investigation forward similarly the
autopsy section uses the evidence
scanners deep tissue and skeletal x-ray
functions to locate specific items
buried within corpses it's so simple and
with hindsight disposable but those
interactions aren't what Batman Arkham
VR is about and that's not what stuck
with me about it
it's the emotionally charged moments in
between that left a lasting impression
the ones that leverage my enduring love
of the character a my familiarity with
the world but placed me at the heart of
it there's a bit where I lowered the
cowl over my face then looked in the
mirror and saw Batman staring back at me
it was a moment that gave me pause and
despite knowing I'm a grown
standing in a dark room with an absurd
looking virtual reality headset strapped
to my face I believed I was Batman for a
moment I was transporting to Gotham see
and I was his greatest hero as I was
lowered deeper on the ground
the metallic elevator gave way to a vast
Kevin bats fluttered through the air
their screeches just barely piercing
through the sound of crashing waterfalls
to my left was the t-rex statue from my
adventure on dinosaur island on the
right was the giant penny that marks my
tussle with the penny plunderer I was in
the Batcave and it was overwhelming I
had seen this place countless times over
my lifetime but never like this never
from this perspective
[Music]
please select vehicle in the bat-cave
garage a summoned the Batmobile and
emerged on a platform stopping right in
front of my face I could finally see
what the Joker twoface and the many
thoughts in Gotham so whenever Batman
rocketed through the streets in pursuit
of villainy and at the touch of a button
it transformed from the nimble pursuit
mode into the tank-like battle mode it
was majestic imposing powerful Arkham VI
also let me get up close with heroes and
villains that I had only seen on flat
planes up until that point I could see
every detail in Nightwing chiseled jaw
and his ripped gymnast physique or the
gruesome appearance of villains that
shalt be named and the alley I was
carefully scouring in stark corners and
soaking up that grimy Gotham atmosphere
that I'd read so much about I stared up
into the sky at the iconic Batman symbol
projected onto the clouds and it made me
smile Batman Arkham VR is barely a game
of all the launch titles for PlayStation
VR it's likely to be the least
mechanically driven but that doesn't
mean it has no value
while playing it I was totally enveloped
in the world and in those moments the
shallow mechanics didn't matter to me I
appreciate that this is a subjective
emotional response based on my lifelong
obsession with the character but it's
also a glimpse into one of the greatest
promises of VR its ability to transport
us into alien worlds and blur the lines
between what's real and what isn't
to give us the opportunity for style and
our real selves and absolutely inhabit
characters we've dreamed of being since
childhood
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]